♪
Danny: I just thought it was a coincidence.
Rya: Danny, are you really willing
to take the blame for this?
♪
Tom: Danny Sullivan
is on trial for a serious crime.
Police: Come out with your hands up.
Tom: He is someone with good intentions.
Tom: But he is a kid who is lost.
♪
Tom: Danny is not from a strong background.
Girl: Loser.
Akiva: He yearns to be normal,
like any teenager.
Akiva: But he struggles and is suffering.
Bill: I'm going to kick you're little wirey ass.
Danny: I'm so sorry
Danny: Please! Please!
♪
Yitzhak: You want to come in, clean yourself up?
Tom: Our whole show is a mystery.
Rya: What about the girl?
Matty: No sign of her either.
I'm thinking that he offed her.
Amanda: Rya Goodwin is a professor
Amanda: She's passionate about her job.
♪
Amanda: She's a way into Danny's psyche.
Amanda: She's trying to save his life.
[Knocking]
Rya: Do you know where she is, Danny?
Danny: I keep telling you, I don't know where she is.
♪
Tom: It is a twisting tale,
a psychological thriller.
Tom: It's a show like no other.
Matty: Do you think these are all victims?
Akiva: Paradigms continue to swing
back and forth like a pendulum.
Danny: What do you want me to say?
Danny: That this whole thing was a setup from the start.
Rya: What if it was?
♪
Tom: I hope that people are gripped.
Tom: I hope that people are shocked.
Philip: He's hiding something.
Rya: If I'm right,
Danny may be innocent.
Rya: Danny.
Where did they all go?
♪